we've Star Wars the last Jedi almost
upon us it's time to ask the important
questions who was Snoke is Luke truly
the last Jedi who were raised parents
and of course who's not going to make it
out alive it's all but a given that
somebody will bite it in the name of
plot progression but some characters are
more likely to rejoin the force and
others these Star Wars favorites stand a
very good chance of not making it to
episode 9 and here's why
Poe Dameron posed a pretty popular and a
likeable character but he's definitely
the third most important hero in the new
trilogy behind Rey and Finn so if one of
the younger good guys has to go it's
almost certainly going to be him
if he does die it would actually be a
long time coming Poe wasn't originally
going to make it out of the force
awakens' of life but actor Oscar Isaac
asked for a bigger role because he was
sick of checking out so early on in his
films ultimately director JJ Abrams
promoted him to main character status
but the fact that they had considered
axing him before suggests they could
consider her again and might want to
find a backup buddy just in case general
Hux if the last Jedi is to be the Empire
Strikes Back of the new trilogy that
means the villains will dominate but
that doesn't mean they all have to
survive because somebody has to take one
for the dark team no way will that be
kylo or Snoke they're too important to
the story score so that means that the
first orders general Hux might be on the
chopping block he's not force sensitive
and he and kylo Ren are constantly at
each other's throats over strategy if
they clash badly enough that snoke's
forced to choose one he's almost
certainly going to choose kylo over the
powerless military dude so what if he's
really really good at commanding
stormtroopers that's not a unique skill
set and Snoke could likely find the
replacement first in fact he's already
got one Captain phasma of course as
she's not a guaranteed survivor of the
sequel either Captain phasma whether or
not hugs meets his end in the last Jedi
phasma may be running out of time as
well and could finally face the Fate she
evaded at the trash compactor in the
force awakens phasma is a pretty popular
character thanks for the fact that she's
female portrayed by Game of Thrones
Gwendoline Christie and rocks some
silver rather than the usual trap whites
but there hasn't been a lot to a
character yet besides being a tough
stoic warrior we haven't seen her face
and we know little about the reason for
what she does and how she feels about
her unless the last Jedi tackles those
issues or at least make some more human
by showing her face losing her wouldn't
really affect Star Wars one way or the
other
Chewbacca just about any original
trilogy character could be knocking on
the midi-chlorians door and the lovable
old Chewie is no different now that his
partner and best buddy Han is no more
and now that we have the pogs to fill
the sagas fuzzy adorable creature quota
Chewbacca's suddenly pretty expendable
besides Chuy's actor Peter Mayhew
is simply too old to continue playing
the role Lucasfilm found another
7-footer to where the fuzzy suits but
it's not easy to recast a character so
beloved it might be prudent for Disney
to give us new guy Chewie for just one
movie so we can say a proper goodbye to
our beloved arm ripping teddy bear then
we can watch him sacrifice himself
aerobic Liam battle taking as many of
the first-order with him as he can
just like harm would have wanted unkar
plutt when we last saw unkar plutt he
was raging because rey refused to sell
him bb-8 and then flew up in the
Millennium Falcon which he claimed was
his aside from that he's been a dangling
plot piece a guy who has no real role
anymore but he hasn't died yet either
despite having his arm ripped off in a
deleted scene someone less the last Jedi
plans to make him a major pain in the
neck for Rey it's best to just end them
in fact get rid of him anyway because he
deserves it Admiral Ackbar of all the
original trilogy characters to survive
this long few are more surprising than
Admiral Ackbar he has no real ties to
the plot and his character is almost
entirely based on his Return of the Jedi
line that the internet meme machine is
immortalized it's a trap
it's a trap aside from that though he's
almost completely expendable
and the one bit of dialogue isn't enough
to justify keeping him around to see the
end of race saga Maz Kanata the wise end
Maz Kanata is a Yoda asked figure for
the new generation but we still don't
know much about her or her intentions
perhaps the mystery is meant to segue
into a spin-off or novelization but
there's also a chance she may just be
meant as a red herring who's ready to
join the other force ghosts the first
order already attacked a planet once so
why not do it again and go after whoever
remains it's likely they'll want to come
after her anyway
if they find out she was the one who
gave Luke's lightsaber to Rey and since
she's not a fighter
despite being force sensitive when she's
in the first order sites her days are
probably numbered call Yoda vibes or not
r2d2 wallet robots life doesn't and the
way fleshy species lives do think of the
emotional wallop if one of the only two
characters to appear in every single
Star Wars movie finally expired if it
were to happen our guesses r2d2 would be
the one to go
while c-3po is certainly beloved there's
something about r2d2 that makes him
extra lovable maybe it's his compact
size maybe it's how he doesn't speak
English
so he can't talk and snark too much like
his chatty golden buddy whatever it is
people adore r2d2 and if he gets damaged
beyond repair during a dogfight Star
Wars may actually bring audiences to
tears Plus since Kenny Baker the actor
who spent the most time inside the r2
suit passed away in August 2016 it only
seems right that the carrot to go with
him so it remains his forever Luke
Skywalker obi-wan became one of the
force so why not the new obi-wan to Jedi
Master Luke Skywalker's getting on in
years his friend han Solo is gone and
his confidence and his ability to train
young Jedi his shots there's no real
reason to thing luck will survive last
Jedi aside from the fact that he's Luke
Skywalker and Star Wars would seem weird
without him but with new fighters like
Ray and Finn now around to pick up the
slack Luke can comfortably join his
father and obi-wan in the pantheon of
force ghosts after all he does give this
grave warning
the Jedi and general Leia after Carrie
Fisher's tragic and untimely passing in
December 2016 people started wondering
what would happen to a Star Wars
character general Leia it's not as
though anyone else can never step into
the role
so surely Leia will be gone alongside er
actress but the character was originally
set to survive the last Jedi to have a
bigger role in episode 9 that's
obviously no longer the case but
director Rian Johnson has said that they
aren't adjusting what happens to her in
this movie based on real-life events
despite his words though the trailer
certainly seems to indicate her fate is
questionable in the last Jedi all the
same thanks for watching click the loop
icon to subscribe to our YouTube channel
plus check out all this cool stuff we
know you love to
[Music]